um so basically courtney taylor is an
only fans model in miami
and she's hot i'm not gonna lie to you
like one to ten i would give her like a
solid ten like she's fine
and she's dating this guy named
christian
okay
and christian and her um seemingly are
the perfect couple on instagram but you
guys know how that
is yes so
seemingly the perfect couple
and then one day the police are called
to their apartment
and he has been stabbed by her
and he actually was taken to the
hospital and he he's bled to death he
died
stop just the ones
i believe it was once i'm not actually
let me know in the comments guys if i
got that wrong
but um i think he was stabbed once like
in the shoulder and he bled to death so
she hit a major artery or something yeah
something like that yeah
um
and now the evidence that's coming out
on this case is a little bit mixed
so the
neighbors said they have seen
him hit her
and that it was a domestic violence case
okay
um however
the friends said they'd seen her hit him
right
and they said he they'd never seen him
hit her and there was accounts of him
like sleeping in
i don't know like different parts of the
building
um
basically
like so she like kicked him out yeah
something like that like it was
basically like there was some accounts
that it was kind of a toxic relationship
right
so when the police get there she
threatens to kill herself
and they bring her to a psych ward
okay
she gets out of the psych ward she gets
eight thousand dollars bail
for killing someone that
some female white privilege there
for killing someone
[Music]
they all what if i kill my girlfriend if
i get eight thousand dollars bail that's
what
that's how i feel um but
um basically she's claiming it was
domestic violence and she did it in
self-defense
um however the friends and family say he
would never do something like this right
but the neighbors say
but we've seen him attack her
now it gets even weirder because
after she gets out of the mental
institution
people start digging into her she has a
lot of duis and she also went on this
podcast in miami and was just kind of
like wild and on there like she was
saying i only f like rich black guys
like
yeah yeah
so she's got tight
so now now okay but then she starts
posting after she gets out
thirst traps
after she's killed yes and so like she
now one what that's one theory
one one one theory is that maybe it was
scheduled right you're a content creator
maybe i would think you know
you could take it off the schedule
with that amount of money that she's
probably making yeah on only fantasies
you could take a break
your boyfriend right and this is a
luxury apartment so this is like they're
in like a very nice
it's like 10k a month to live there so
so 8k bail is nothing she's out she's
partying and like
people are following her around
basically like when she's partying being
like what are you what are you doing
yeah because it's kind of a bad look
like your boyfriend
yes it is it's not great isn't it no no
and on top of that on top of that she
didn't go to the funeral
i'm i mean i don't know if you were like
i mean she murdered him
yeah i think that's not going to be
probably got jumped if she rides yeah
exactly right because if i was
if i was the family member of that guy
or his friend she would get jumped like
no doubt about it i'm sorry but a black
family don't play about that
you're gonna just murder my
my family and turn up at the funeral
right
let's play devil's advocate for her
right
long there's been a long history of
domestic disputes courtney has called
the police seven times in the last month
on him
okay
yes yes like he definitely has he ever
called
for her
not
the evidence so far no no so far okay
because men don't really report domestic
abuse you know that right they don't
really report no no
um
so she has not actually been
formally charged or i guess she hasn't
been charged i don't i heard mixed
things about this the the last video i
watched said she i think she just was
but she was on like bail like it was 8k
so she can get out
i don't i should so they're yet to go to
trial then yes yes okay
um but now
another thing happens okay
florida is a stand your ground state do
you know what that means
yeah um i personally did not until i
googled it
together i've heard of it before
um so
prosecutors must thoroughly disprove a
self-defense claim before filing legal
action so she's saying it's self-defense
so prosecutors have to disprove that
right which is going to be difficult
because she has called police seven
times in the last month
now
it gets even more racy okay
because then they start going through
his tweets
and they find out this man
was tweeting about how he only dates
white girls and saying some pretty like
derogatory things about so she's saying
showing dates black guys he's saying he
only dates wagner yeah let me let me
find out they sound like they sound like
a match
i was going to say a match made in hell
but sure
so i mean they found each other one of
them died but i guess yeah so christian
but but so christian purgatory
so christian's old tweets
oh no it's not loading they were they
were pretty bad though like along the
lines of like like white girls boobs are
better than black girls boot like
flashing black women and said all lives
matter
coming i mean it's like
if if he likes white girls so be it do
you know what i mean but don't like like
white girls and then hate other people
which i mean i've always said to people
if you like something like it yeah i
mean like do it in the positive not in
the next yeah why are you going to hate
other people
so no no so there's a lot of people
coming forward that like like the from
the black community that say well you
didn't you didn't like support us when
you were alive so why should we care
basically like a lot of there's a lot of
women like coming forward and saying
okay
right especially saying like oh y'all
biebs are [ __ ] and white goes right
okay
so black girls disgrace themselves on tv
in another i'm tired of these black
girls in my government class
do you got what is your take on the case
you've heard all the evidence that i
know let me know if i missed anything in
the chat
but what do you guys think happened
i mean i read this story i'm gonna be
completely honest here i read it and i
had to read it again because
the first thing that came to mind was
you've killed someone
and you're out in public right so you've
been in hospital because you you know
you're suicidal
and then you're out at a bar with your
dad a couple days later right
so hang on a minute
in my brain you have stabbed someone to
death whether or not it'd be
manslaughter self-defense you've killed
someone and you're out in public
now if it roles were reversed and it was
him
do we think that would happen absolutely
no no no no
and especially he's a black man too yeah
do you know what i mean so that would
have weighed on that would have helped
people out what this
black man is out in public after killing
this
angelic white girl or something i don't
know how would i know everybody would
have painted it you know what i mean
it's just not right for me and the fact
that she was then posting on only fans i
think two days after the incident
happened i mean
is that maybe i don't
because i think anyone who does that is
normal
no like it's so disrespectful
and the fact like
i just if that was a dude or even a
black girl like i think that the
situation would be completely different
like i think they would be in jail yeah
100
i think the optics just look crazy about
it because both scenarios look plausible
it looks like there was some sort of
domestic thing between both of them
because they're just toxic for each
other it's a combination he's hitting
her he's hitting him she's reacted and
obviously eventually killed him but even
if you kill someone even with
self-defense
by your conscience you can murder
someone i've gotta literally be
withdrawn and just not not see the world
the fact that you're partying thinking
was that deliberate don't you have any
sort of remorse because her life has
been taken
maybe she plan she could have planned it
well and that's the that's the other
thing like
i was telling i was telling jessica
earlier when we were talking about this
like i think that men are abused more
than women
and i don't think it's necessarily
because like what type of abuse you
talking about like physically i think
women like hit men all the time men just
don't report it yeah i'm not like i've
been slapped in the face before yeah and
i think i'm gonna report it yeah yeah
but i think it's because it's out before
i'd lit up the whole place but you know
like but i don't i don't necessarily
actually because because if that happens
right and he reacts the way he's
supposed to react yeah he he already
knows that it's going to be exactly nice
yeah once once the police get called
yeah he's going to be seen as aggressive
i will challenge you on this one pearly
in terms of like i don't think
men get physically abused by women that
much i think it's more emotionally
yeah you see because think about it from
a perspective females are really good
with their words women yeah women okay
i'll say that women are really good
what's wrong with females yeah are good
with their good with their words
something to do with the left side of
the brain so they could literally tear a
mouth limb for limb and because a man
can't verbally respond yeah we don't
that's the same way so what do we do the
only thing we know is
we use different i think i don't
necessarily think like are you not
condoning domestic violence no i'm just
explaining that
the dynamics of it
just to clarify i just think when you
take away the consequences of anything
like people will do it more and we see
women like the consequences are taken
away they can get away with it more than
men can
and and so
why because the justice system doesn't
favor men
like men get three times the like i
think i think it's either three or four
times the sentencing for the same crime
so is that because
um
women are able to
is that because they're seen as more
delicate creatures
i think so yeah is that what you think
yeah probably but
also and they can cry yeah also if you
cry you just automatically even from me
yeah ultimately believe her because you
think yourself why would she cry if it's
not true and i think women know that and
that's what and i just
well i think there's like there's shitty
women and there's good women there's
shitty men and there's good men but i
think when you give like people like i
think even shitty men will think um i
don't want to go to jail
you know like you know like maybe maybe
i shouldn't hit her because like i want
to drop the soul yeah yeah but so so if
you give like shitty people the
opportunity to get away with stuff like
she killed him eight grand like that's
crazy that eight grand thing is crazy
correct me if i'm wrong florida is one
of the states whereby they've still got
the capital punishment system so if
she's effectively killed someone she
could be on death row
yeah but
it should be yeah but then again this is
not murder this is mostly most likely
manslaughter i don't think she
deliberately wanted to kill him i think
it was more of a case of a domestic
that's gone wrong
do we know but that's still not
remorseful issues regardless of how it
went usually when it comes to capital
punishment in whichever states that it
happens in they still go with
you're either going to get murdered or
you're getting life
but there's a distinction between
manslaughter and murder can i just say
on manslaughter i don't understand why
the walk movement haven't gravitated
towards that because it's manslaughtered
it should be said it's people it's
people's shoulder
like is that what it should be or
woman's slaughter no no no it puts men
in a bad way it's like non-binary snorer
i don't know what i mean i think you've
started
a debate for another day right yeah i'm
just saying that it's not manslaughter
anymore guys it's like person slaughter
what do you guys think so do you guys
think there was
like she would have any case in like
like do you think she was being abused
in that relationship based on the
evidence based on evidence sounds like
they were both being abused i agree i
agree completely now there's also an
article that states that
well
again what what what do you believe that
he was involved in human trafficking and
that she was being trafficked mm-hmm so
this is another thing that's that's a
home okay i didn't hear about this so
yeah yeah go ahead was that another
story that came up yeah yeah i think i
think it was on the daily
daily mirror yep that he was trafficking
her
but that's yet to be proof how long were
they together do you know i thought it
was a couple years i thought it was like
that's not human trafficking no i don't
i mean they yeah
no
i mean i i can't comment too much
but that's that's what they were going
with as you know a defense for her
i think they're trying to
they're trying to paint a picture of him
yeah and why doesn't her lawyer tell her
to put her phone away
like
like he probably knows that she's going
to get away with it regardless
if we're being honest here they know
that they don't have to push as hard
especially if it's a white woman all it
takes is some crocodile tears for her to
get away with this and she's good to go
put the grape sign on there and before
you know it
you know
that's that
i'm sure i'm sure it sounds like in the
coming months we're going to hear
more from her
and she'll probably not like we can hear
from him yeah
[Music]
and she'll probably spin a story of some
kind of i don't know there's going to be
a netflix show on it yeah that's right
he was so
well that's the thing with these like
that's the thing with it's like we're
rewarding bad behavior with the media
because now like she's gonna be a
celebrity basically everyone's saying
that though don't as the audience want
that
we want those trashed stories because we
eat it up because the media won't
promote it if there was an audience for
it i know you've got awesome well
they're just consuming this crap well
it's more like the justice system should
come in and we should be able to hate
them in prison
you know like
at the very least like you know ted
bundy was well known but we could hate
him in prison yeah he's a celebrity you
know
yeah well it's the same thing with the
tinder swindler though him a career
delusion when it comes to ted bundy and
all of them because like how many movies
have we had on ted bundy alone yo
they're the amount of sexualizing that
they've done to this man and
romanticizing
it's like people forgot that he quite
literally murdered people yeah but it
doesn't kind of speak to the psychology
of
this world like people are abs like they
find murder quite
i mean that's intriguing
you know i mean
that's because
people who run media made it that way
they could have made it more informative
and more disgusting i guess to repulse
people but instead when you look at like
the one with zac efron for example like
that movie where he played as ted bundy
it really romanticized the hell out of
that movie i watched it and i was like
he murdered people right like yeah just
wanted a reminder yeah but it's easy to
blend the media but then again if the
audience is not there to have it we love
to watch those stories sex and violence
yeah it sells yeah i'm not even gonna
lie like that ted bundy netflix here it
was fire like i can't even
i can't i can't in the series but i know
that the movie itself was like uh i
think it speaks to the primal
there's something in human beings that's
quite primal exactly you know what i
mean exactly and and when we see that
kind of stuff either sex or violence it
sparks something exactly look at the
subconscious yeah you look at you look
at history you look at when the
gladiators but they were killing each
other look how the auditoriums
[Music]
those guys got girls exactly not to
mention what happened in mark i think
marble large when they used to do the
executions yeah yeah people came ahead
and didn't watch it yeah it's stuff like
that people came to watch lynch exactly
there's something in the human psyche i
believe no i agree but it's it's kind of
like
it's like everyone it's like that even
getting immediate you probably
understand the snout too a little bit
better because once you start creating
content you realize like how much the
titles and stuff you have to make it
like click baity because you almost want
to outrage people so they'll like click
it you're like the more juicy the
headline or do you see the thumbnail
because people want to see the
outrageous stuff they do they just do
well i guess part of that is it makes
people feel better about themselves in
their own lives when they've got their
own things going on that
there's really bad stuff going out there
actually my life seems pretty you know
okay yeah and also it makes you feel
like a good person because you're
thinking well i'm not that bad
i might be a bit effed up but i'm not
that bad i didn't do that yeah yeah